okay gents so five years can be a long
time I think in the music business right
now you know a lot of artists these days
are used to putting something out every
year or every few months did you ever
worry that your fan base in particular
was gonna kind of move on well I know I
don't think we really thought about it
because well you know we we kind of went
at it so hard for so long that we just
basically needed to do something
different for a couple years
ya know it started with Dan - doing his
other band the arts that and that led
into a solo record that would into me
having a kid and before you know it was
like I mean I didn't have my records
didn't have anything to do with him
having a kid but you know life happens
you know yeah but it's cool that me in
five years it's like I think I feels
like a long time for our last record but
then I look at some of our friends like
you know Vampire Weekend or Arcade Fire
see they like to do healthy distances
between records actually - sometimes
they do four or five years - we just
kind of or constantly go out every 18
months for a while in fact in the first
two years of the band we put out three
albums yeah that was a kind of pace we
were at yeah it's crazy because you know
we didn't really have radio success
until our sixth record fifth record six
right yeah six records so we've we've
made five records into zigzagged all
across Canada and North America you know
so it's you haven't a nice break was
like a long time coming
yeah that decision to take the time off
was that just the two of you or was that
did you get some words of wisdom from
some of your contemporaries saying maybe
it's time you guys need to just chill
out a bit
um no one told us to chill out a little
bit but I think we just both
instinctually knew that it was the right
time I think we just kind of needed to
needed to take a break we'd been hitting
it so hard that it was like it was an
assessee at that point yeah yeah it was
like you know I said it took five years
you made five albums for us to get a
title on the radio which is almost ten
years of work
and then when that happened I think it
was that's when work started oh man
that's awesome
but yeah we ended up having to do like
500
yeah and then we did that in three or
four year period and it was just you
know and you know coming from the place
that we did where was just the two of us
in a van a minivan zigzagging I mean we
we would drive like 12 hours a day to
get paid $50 to play yeah it was so then
when we did have success it was really
hard for us it's another one say no to
money right right when it was so hard
for us to make when we started so it was
just like this as part of that that fear
of you know they well if we stop now you
know we know what it's like to not have
this so she's not in that yeah yeah
absolutely and I think we were both kind
of um we both worried about that kind of
stuff I mean because you know it was so
day-to-day when we started mm-hmm four
years really I mean it was the idea of
even having pain one employee was crazy
too so that it was insane yeah yeah when
we got a bus we couldn't believe it yeah
yeah so uh yeah I mean the break it's
like I feel it was inevitable after
working so hard and then things kind of
just naturally we just basically had
this we have a show booked in San
Francisco August of 2015 and we just
didn't book anything after that just
left it open mm-hmm and then well year
went by two years went by and then the
third year we started the record yes
really not that crazy long a break but
it was enough time for us to we'd get
re-centered I think you kind of start
feeling a little out of touch when you
spend you know 200 days a year on the
road he's trying yeah your life is
prioritized
in a whole different way than when you
have responsibilities at home and for us
we started as a recording project
because we love making music and when
you're on the road you can't make music
you're performing music so it's you know
both of us needed our time to kind of
just create and men and you know we got
to work with a bunch of great artists
and musicians and help different people
and it's been really good for both of us
I bet that you had said you know you
wouldn't get this project back together
until you can figure out that whole
conundrum of like I don't wanna spend
too
20 days of the year away from my house
well that's the problem is that it is
true I mean I think that we've had to
figure out how to make it work for us it
moving into our 40s we just had to
figure out how to accept turning down a
lot of money it's like it's like you
know because we've had that we're you
know we're blessed that we have fans all
over the world which means we could
spend forever being going all over the
world mm-hmm
but we just have to say no at a certain
point and which one of you is more apt
to say yes which one of you is more apt
to say to be able to turn down like an
offer that someone's giving you I think
we're both very much the same yeah yeah
I know which makes it with a lot of ways
we have the exact same instincts when it
comes that stuff so it's like the things
that made us say yes you know are the
back and they were the same and things
would make us valley not want to do
something are the same but you know what
you know we're gonna I think moving for
we're gonna play less shows but I think
that's gonna make them all more special
yes we actually play at the time way
working with those other artists all
those other projects that you guys have
had do you feel that made you better
musicians or is that more just like was
that flexing a different kind of muscle
for you guys yeah I don't know that any
it's so subjective and there's nothing
better we just were different people you
know yeah we've grown we've experienced
everything met different people and I'm
not the same person I was just a couple
years ago I know that literally his DNA
has been Galilei yeah there's a gamma
ray the the video for go is I mean I
love it I think it's amazing that you
guys take that idea of I wasn't wearing
the same you were exactly the same
I wear the same thing every day I was
like do I have to wear anything special
for the video they're like no just where
would you normally do I wash this shirt
because I have two shirts yeah but you
it pokes a lot of fun at the idea of
just like not being able to open up and
communicate and all those fun things
that are happening that are like signs
of passive aggression and it I think is
really cool though when it came time to
actually get this thing back together to
get the Black Keys back together was
there and hesitation like who called
person said I'm ready to do this it was
just a natural natural you know thing
that happened yeah I mean cuz we'd been
in contact with each other and you know
we're always talking with our manager
and we just put it on the books we put
it in that we didn't really talk about
it no we just put it on the calendar
yeah then then when the day came we
should both showed up and we just
started yeah
and that was it and it was like it was
it was great because it was really fun
cuz we hadn't done it on sand so long it
felt exciting and it was like it was
great really
you